Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new star wars the
mandalorian season 2 video we have a
bunch of big announcements they finally
reveal the release date we know what's
going on with the trailer
they confirm some of the big characters
and details so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
of course i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes when it gets here so be
sure to subscribe to get all those i'll
do a disney plus giveaway too all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
during season 2 or what you hoped that
they did during season 2 because all
the episodes are already done
but just going down the list starting
with number five the mandalorian season
2 episode 1
is starting october 30th if that seems a
little bit later than you expected they
confirmed it would be october earlier
this year but they didn't say when
i'll explain why that is because they
made a couple big changes to
all the stuff that's happening on disney
plus for basically the second half of
the year because of the virus
there are eight episodes total just like
season one and the finale is going to come
in the middle of december so the
mandalorian season 2 will basically
run through the rest of the year if
you're a big fan of the marvel avengers
stuff the disney plus series they have
like falcon and winter soldier in one
division that are coming to disney plus
later this year or that we're supposed
to i'll explain that at the end of the
video
but if you are in a deep sarlacc pit of
despair because 2020 has been such a
crap year
john favreau already revealed that
they're well underway
on the mandalorian season 3 production
and there won't be any major delays with
getting season 3 episodes out by the end
of next year
right now for instance they're actually
using the outdoor sets from the
mandalorian season 2 to get ready to
film the star wars obi-wan kenobi series
i know there's a lot of rumors about
hayton christensen coming back for duel
darth vader and anakin skywalker
flashbacks darth maul coming back for
that
other people like ahsoka temuera
morrison coming back as rex
but number four the major new characters
in the new story of the mandalorian
season 2 they finally confirmed
moth gideon capturing baby yoda as part
of his larger
experiments in cloning in force
sensitive clones the darksaber his
history with the mandalorian people the
great purge
and the reveal that he himself is force
sensitive
it shouldn't be a big surprise he's
written and designed to be the darth
vader of the series he wears black armor
just like darth vader flies a special
tie fighter just like darth vader even
though his is called the thai outlander
or it was until the mandalorian blew it
up
he also wears a space cape and wields a
lightsaber just like darth vader
people refer to it as the dark saber but
it is just another type of lightsaber
the way giancarlo esposito explains it
is that maf gideon has a strong
connection to the force but he himself
wasn't trained to be a jedi or a sith
he's not like a failed padawan that
escaped order 66 like during jedi fallen
order
the emperor had special programs for
force sensitive children that it
captured and indoctrinated
most of them were twisted using sith
tech and severe psychological
conditioning to become either
inquisitors or dark side
assassins who just existed as part of
their own special black ops branch of
the empire
a lot of the animated series like star
wars the clone wars
rebels the games like star wars jedi
fallen order explore
those characters a lot more but during
the regular imperial era during the
reign of the emperor in the original
trilogy of movies
in the period covering the mandalorians
great purge moff gideon was still just a
regular
officer in the imperial security bureau
test with handling the sector of space
that included the planet mandalore
so number three he's around his early
50s in the events of the mandalorian
series so working back
in that timeline from that he would have
started his career as a regular republic
junior officer
during the prequel era of movies before
the rise of the emperor
that means that even if he were force
sensitive at the time he never went
through any official jedi training
because back then
the jedi temple was still very active
the jedi order it was before order 66
and they never took adult padawans so he
would have never
been trained as a jedi or anything like
that so that's how he flew under the
emperor's radar when it came to being a
force-sensitive person working in the
military
by giancarlo esposito says that maf
gideon is very studied in his academic
knowledge and historical knowledge of
the force he appreciates it
as an idea he's obsessed with harnessing
its power to achieve his goals in
reunifying the galaxy under a new empire
of course led by him like he respects
the force but it's just a means to an
end for him
that's where his connection to the
darksaber comes in so he's not just
a regular really powerful imperial moth
that's stealing ancient
artifacts just because he thinks they
look cool the darksaber for him is sort
of a symbol of what he thinks his own
potential is like i'm force sensitive
think of the evil villain monologue that
gives me great power and with that great
power i'm going to bring my own order to
the galaxy
the darksaber itself within the history
of the mandalorian culture has always
been used
symbolically as a sign of leadership as
well it as a member of the imperial
security bureau he's tasked with
information gathering so he's spent a
lot of time reading about the history of
the galaxy in the history of cultures in
the galaxy that they're busy going
around conquering
number two ahsoka is listed on the imdb
for episode
1 but that can be unreliable because
anybody can edit imdb
i don't know how many episodes she's
going to be in exactly but probably not
every single one
each different episode tends to be its
own separate adventure or bounty with
just a loose
continuity between them in a basic
character arc with a couple of
characters reappearing in most of the
episodes like greef carga or cara dune
boba fett will be featured obviously but
he's only supposed to appear
a little i believe the concept is is
that he's not going to be in that many
episodes during
season 2 but he'll be a bigger
character during the mandalorian season
three and more of an antagonist for the
mandalorian
during season three so if you've been
getting hyped up for the mandalorian
versus boba fett it sounds like they're
building up to that
because baked into the whole concept of
the series they even said i think it was
cara dunes character that repeated the
lines the mandalorians aren't a people
they're a creed it's all about this way
of life that they live by
and boba fett is sort of like a
pretender mandalorian just wearing their
armor the funny thing is though is that
during the series because this is after
return of the jedi he's climbed out of
the sarlacc pit
he does not actually wear his classic
trademark armor from the original
trilogy so they'll explain that during
season 2 timothy olyphant is also
starring during the season
he was actually supposedly seen on set
wearing boba fett's armor but because
temuera morrison is playing boba fett
during the series
a lot of people theorize that timothy
olyphant is actually playing a character
from the aftermath novel called cobb
vanth which deals with what happens to
boba fett after he crawls out of the
sarlacc he's basically a sheriff of a
town
in tatooine near the sarlacc pit he buys
boba fett's armor off of a bunch of
jawas and just wears it in the normal
line of duty as he is a sheriff
so that's why during the mandalorian
season 1 episode 5 when you see this
post credit scene with boba fett with
those special spurs on his boots
walking up just clinking inspecting
mienna's body
but he's not wearing the trademark
mandalorian armor from the original
trilogy
katee sackhoff is also supposed to be
coming back to play
Bo Katan Kryze she did the voice for
that character during the clone wars and
during star wars rebels she's the last
known wielder
of the darksaber before the original
trilogy events so if mob gideon stole it
from someone he stole it from her
so either she'll be featured in
flashbacks for the great purge or for a
context
or she'll show up in present day if
she's still alive in present day
number one though getting to the baby
yoda of it all big thing finally meeting
another former jedi
ahsoka because that was the big mission
that he was tasked with find his kind
also trying to find out where he came
from as well which is sort of a separate
task
i know everyone's still posting all the
memes of mori povich and yoda with
yaddle like where did he come from who
are his parents
yoda probably isn't his father it's
probably just two other creatures of his
race it's just that they're so rare that
when a new one is found
in the galaxy it's a huge huge deal
when you think about how old baby yoda
actually is he's in his 50s he's
actually about the same age as anakin
skywalker would be
so he would have been born sometime
before the events of the prequels
since it's a new season we'll also
probably see him using surprise new
force powers that nobody knew that he
had
he's already used basic telekinesis to
lift the mud horn he's used force push
to block the fire
the season one finale he's used force
choke on cara dune
and he used force heal on greef carga
which is a pretty advanced ability
there are a billion different types of
force abilities that are really cool
and visually stunning that they could
roll out on the show but the biggest one
if we're talking about original trilogy
easter eggs and references
would just be basic mind control basic
jedi mind trick
i don't think we're going to see him use
any kind of crazy force lightning since
that's viewed as more of a sith
technique and very very aggressive
and his hands are way too tiny to
actually work a lightsaber but giancarlo
esposito says that baby yoda does have
scenes with him when he's using the
darksaber like a fight scene and baby
yoda is just completely fascinated by it
like what is that shiny thing i wanna
touch it so bad
please give it to me but like i
mentioned earlier in the video the big
thing about them scheduling the
mandalorian to start at the end of
october
and running it through the end of the
year is probably because marvel will not
wind up releasing falcon in winter
soldier or wandavision episodes until
the beginning of next year at the
earliest
but the big news with the mandalorian
season 2 trailer that's probably going
to come in the next two weeks for those
of you wondering when we're going to get
new footage
i'll be sure to post that when they
release it and i'll be doing bonus
videos for the series as they make more
announcements so leave all your video
requests
in the comments below everyone click
here for my chadwick
boseman tribute video may he rest in
power and you can click here for all my
mandalorian
episode videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
this is the way!